and now let's meet Germany's number 10
Jennifer Morrison
she's the German women's team's star
player and at 23 she's already achieved
a lot winning a clutch of titles
including the Women's European
Championship in 2013 and in May she and
her club FFC Frankfurt won the Champions
League congratulations on your Champions
League win thank you very much do you
believe that talent is something you're
born with I ask because your father was
a professional footballer and your
brother also played dad set the example
my brother David was also football crazy
he'd come home from school and go
straight to the kickabout area with the
ball under his arm at first I had to
sneak after him he didn't enjoy taking
me with him it was awkward because I was
his little sister as you can imagine but
after a while he grew really proud of me
and wanted to take me along he always
asked me himself if I wanted to go play
with him and his friends and that was my
childhood I spent most of my time on the
football field with the guys that was my
life from school to the football pitch
until really late and obviously I had to
do homework and then to bed you weren't
even 15 when you made your Bundesliga
debut and soon after you scored your
first Bundesliga goal did you know that
would be your career and to be honest I
never really thought about it I just
wanted to play football and I let things
happen around me
I see in the attackee night I was just
living in the moment and didn't think
about it of course I've always heard
Jenny we're gonna see you on TV and I
always thought yeah if that's the case
then that's the case I didn't put myself
under pressure when I look back I'm very
proud of how everything developed smart
ends ear starts keep this then do you
have role models in women's football for
a bit I hated
yes my role model was always Nadine
Kessler she'll be missed and I hope she
gets better soon
websites and obviously at 13 I threw her
balls as a ball girl and then I played
with her that was obviously huge for me
and we both managed to play in the
national team together it's really a
crazy story I have to say she was always
my role model I think the best player is
Marta what she brings to the field with
her technique and dynamics is really
top-notch you've won a lot of awards now
the World Cup is coming up yes how do
you feel about that is that the title
that's still missing you know to missing
teeth
yes of course that's a title that's
still missing you think this put inside
but I think we have potential as a team
we were a unit on and off the pitch and
you can see that you can feel it too
I think that's a very important factor
where should women's football be in 20
years what are your hopes
just wish we get more attention and the
more games would be shown on TV and
perhaps the Bundesliga did you know that
all the Swedish women's league matches
were shown live on TV this year I didn't
know that but it's great what do you
look forward to most in the tournament
in a tournament you have to be in top
form you can't let yourself slip up I'd
say that's not pressure but rather
motivation it depends I'm looking
forward to it the best thing would be if
it started tomorrow long nosed game